[Applause]
campaigns are at Full Throttle across
Latin America ahead of presidential
elections in
2024 at least six nations from Uruguay
to the Dominican Republic are due to
elect new leaders amid dismal Regional
economic
growth the biggest challenge for Latin
America in the short term is preserving
democracy despite the economic and
political adversities especially as poll
showed disenchanted citizens support
democracy less and
less
in El Salvador an embolden NA buele is
expected to cruise to re-election as
president after circumventing
constitutional restrictions that forbid
him from
running his supporters adore him for
crushing the country's gangs but critics
say the move cements him as an
autocrat tired of Decades of violence
salvadorians have overlooked accusations
of Human Rights abuses in exchange for
peace continuity is also what Mexico's
ruling party is hoping for in June's
election said to be the largest in the
country's history history will be made
no matter who wins here as two women
face each other on the ballot Mexico's
first female president an important
landmark in one of the most dangerous
countries for women in the
region further south in Venezuela Paul
suggests opposition candidate Maria
Corina Machado has an overwhelming lead
over president Nicolas Maduro
but few believe Maduro will relinquish
power no matter what the ballots
say there are no Democratic conditions
in Venezuela for a competitive election
basically the ruling party will win and
that will be
that the country Remains the source of
record number of migrants reaching the
US border hundreds of thousands of Latin
Americans have already made their
opinions clear long before the polls
open by risking their lives on the
journey North to the United States but
in a region still heavily affected by us
politics perhaps just as influential to
Latin America this year will be the race
to the White House in November Julia
gallano Al jazer Mexico
City make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer